>>Courtney: A text can
sometimes be very intimidating,
especially for a struggling
reader, an English language learner.
Art is a universal language.
Every child can read a piece of art.
They're able to give an opinion, they're
able to find evidence in that work
because they can read the visual.
It's a place where every
child can be successful.
>>Student: Now, it's making sense.
>>Courtney: At Concourse
Village Elementary School,
we are a literacy-based school.
We believe that every
educator is teaching reading,
so you're learning reading in
music, you're learning reading
in physical education, you're
learning reading in art.
>>Teacher: You're going to get
an artwork that you're going
to have a discussion with your--
>>Courtney: When you're reading a book,
you have words that are
communicating the idea.
Artwork is the same concept,
except it's visuals
that are communicating that idea.
>>Ivelisse: We're reading the
pictures, but not with our mouth.
We're reading it with our eyes.
>>Courtney: So second grade is
learning about three different types
of communities, rural, urban,
and suburban communities.
>>Each group has your master work that
you're looking at with a question.
Our first group is Romare
Bearden's The Block. What would it--
>>So there's different literacy
strategies, such as making connections,
visualizing, prediction inference,
and these are the same strategies
that you can use to read
a piece of artwork.
>>Ivelisse: The picture I was asked to
look at looks like a suburban community,
a single home and the
question was what was the mood,
if it's happy, if it's a sad picture.
That goes with different colors.
>>Courtney: What is the mood
of this artwork? Ivelisse?
>>Ivelisse: It would feel
calming because the evidence,
for me, was the light tone colors.
>>Courtney: The artist's use of
light colors create a happy mood.
>>Thinking of a prediction
question, what might it feel
like to be inside this work and why?
>>Provide evidence from
the work to support.
>>Sebastian: She told us to
look carefully, and then,
think how would it feel
like to be in that picture.
I noticed that there's a crowd
and they're listening to music.
>>It will feel kind of
jammy on that street.
>>Courtney: What do you mean by that?
>>Sebastian: It will feel cool
to be on a street with a lot
of music and a lot of people.
>>Courtney: When you go
back to your tables today,
you're going to revise your
work thinking about these ideas.
>>So after the master work session,
they can apply these literacy
ideas to their own work.
What is the mood of my work?
What am I trying to communicate?
What's my theme?
>>Sebastian: So we continued our
pictures. I was doing the city.
>>Courtney: The sky comes all
the way down to the street.
>>Sebastian: Oh.
>>Courtney: Remember, horizon line.
>>Sebastian: I could ask myself
how I know it's an urban community.
I put a deli store right
next to a lot of buildings.
>>Courtney: We need to do our gallery
walk and provide our feedback.
>>The same way that we critique master
work, we critique each other's work.
>>I hear a lot of oohs and ahs.
>>Sebastian: We went on a gallery
walk. You look at your peers' work.
I might ask what is the
mood in this picture?
What are you trying to tell me.
>>Courtney: I would like to hear some
of the feedback that you received.
>>Ivelisse: I like how she painted.
>>Courtney: Why did you choose to
paint the solar panel with glitter?
>>Ivelisse: It would
show the electricity.
>>Courtney: That's a really
great artistic decision.
>>So because we embed
literacy in the arts,
students find these cross-curricular
connections.
A lot of the vocabulary
transfers over, mood, tone,
atmosphere, prediction, inference.
Art is kind of an entry point for them.
It allows them to really be
creative and be critical thinkers.